Les amis, la dernière fois que j'ai convoqué 10 amis youtubeurs ça s'est extrêmement mal passé.
Nous avons échoué au challenge.
Savez-vous pourquoi nous avons échoué ?
Car un homme ne peut rien faire, s'il n'est pas accompagné d'une femme pour le soutenir.
- Natoo : Mytho
- Eh oh eh attends !
Les amis aujourd'hui, nouveau challenge ! Un jeu auquel j'ai joué il y a 4 ans sur ma chaîne Youtube : Cat Mario !
Aujourd'hui ce sont des youtubeuses qui vont me venir en aide pour arriver au bout de ce jeu.
Certaines ont déjà joué à des jeux, d'autres un peu moins.
Ça va être très amusant, ET C'EST PARTI !
*Toque à la porte*
SWANN PÉRISSÉ !
As-tu déjà joué aux jeux vidéo ?
- Swann : Euuuh, bien sûr, tous les soirs !
- À quoi tu joues tout les soirs ?
- Alors en vrai, j'ai jamais joué aux jeux vidéo.
- OOOOOH
Tu connais Mario ?
- Euuuh, oui j'y ai joué quand j'étais en CM2.
- Tu te souviens bien de ton année de CM2 ?
- AAAH ! LÀ ATTENTION ! ÇA VA TOMBER !
- WHAT C'EST INCROYABLE ELLE A RÉUSSI ! C'EST INCROYABLE ! MAIS C'EST INCROYABLE !
- AAAH *rires*
- T'as eu le checkpoint du premier coup.
- Alors je sais pas ce que ça veut dire "checkpoint".
- Check... *rires*
Excuse-moi, c'était un rire condescendant de gros connard de merde ! Je suis vraiment désolé. *rires*
Je sais que tu ne fais pas partie de ces gens là.
- OH ! NON !
- OOOOOH *rires*
Ah t'es enfermée ! Tu vas mourir.
[Mort nulle]
Je trouve que tu es très forte !
- Ouais merci !
- Je t'ai appelé pour le niveau 1, je me suis dit : "Ouais elle va peut-être un peu galérer..."
- Condescendance !
- Condescendance totale... *rires*
Et au final tu m'as vraiment fait fermer ma gueule.
Tu appelles quelqu'un quand tu veux.
- D'accord.
- Après y'a juste d'autres youtubeuses qui attendent...
- AAAH qu'est ce qui ce passe ? Regarde regarde ! J'vais y aller mmmh... Voilà ! *rires*
*ascenseur émotionnel*
- AAAN... Nan alors ça je suis désolée, un nuage c'est pas méchant comme ça.
- Alors déjà t'en sais rien !
- Bon allez,  j’essaie une dernière fois et après je vais chercher une copine.
- Ok !
- Attention !
- Alors oublie pas : il faut apprendre de ses erreurs pour avancer.
- La prison est là !
- Voilà c'est ça, elle est là !
Donc en gros, faut que tu sautes sur le cube, juste...
- ATTENTION !
- NON ! ATTENTION !
NAN MAIS TU TOMBES DROIT DANS LA PRISON SWANN !
*rires* MAIS C'EST INCROYABLE !
- Petit saut.
*Squeezie rit*
- Hop ! Attention ! Attention !
- Oh putain !
- Oui regarde mais... Les gens calmes, les gens qui maitrisent savent...
- Putain elle donne des leçons c'est incroyable, elle est si forte...
- AAAH !
- Et voilà ! Putain Swann c'est incroyable !
- Il est temps d'aller chercher quelqu'un qui à un meilleur niveau que moi.
- Tu t'es vraiment extrêmement bien débrouillée.
- Merci, je veux une médaille.
- Tiens regarde, tu repars avec ce trophée... Dessus y'a marqué : "Cat Mario pour Swann Périssé".
C'est marqué... Nan mais après regarde pas trop après, fait juste confiance.
- *rires* D'accord !
*Squeezie rit*
- Il faut , IL FAUT OUVRIR LA PORTE ! *rires*
- Ouiiiii !
Natoo : Je suis venue avec la youtubeuse Natoo !
- Natoo et Natsu !
- C'est ça !
- ALORS !
- T'as déjà joué à Mario ?
- Mario oui ! Là le monsieur avec la pastèque sur la tête c'est normal ?
- *en riant* Oui c'est normal !
- Il faut surtout pas que tu le touches.
Sauf si tu... tu...
- Et alors ?
- OOOOOH C'EST INCROYABLE !
- ATTENTION LA PRISON !
- Elle est où la prison ? Elle est où la prison ?
- Bah là t'es dedans Natoo, t'es dedans !
- Mais naaan !
- Regarde saute !
- Aaaaah l'enculé !
- Il faut vraiment que tu meurs pour pouvoir recommencer.
- D'accord ! Beau message ! Il faut se suicider pour repartir de plus belle !
Attention ça ne se passe pas comme ça dans la vie les enfants !
- Mais arrêtez !
- Sur le petit à coté ! Juste en face !
- AAAAAAAAAN !
- Oui ! Oui !
- Oh je l'ai !
au pire tu prends! VOILA VOILA! et là! tu vas sur le tuyau vert
ok ! mais je crois y'a peux être un piège j'en sais rien! on n'a pas vu encore!
C'EST BIEN! ok ok ok ok ok
j'suis sûre que le nuage c'est un enculé
LE MECHANT!
ne touche pas le nuage!
ok et la... AAAAAHHHHHHH!
je tremble des mains
un petit peu de jus
j'ai euuuh l'hépatite c
*recrache*
tu débloques le cube invisible ET T'ES DANS LA PRISON C'EST INCROYABLE
moi ça m'énerve
c'est à cause de lui làà
mais il à rien fait REGARDE SA GUEULE!
il m'a poussé dans le dos
Natsu, tu ne pousses pas Natoo dans le dos c'est pas bien
RAAAH attention le nuaaaage
c'est risqué
MAIS NAN! MAIS NAN!
Natoo, réessaie tu vas y arriver
elle tape de la jambe!
elle est incroyable
en plus elle est comme ça!
*imite Natoo*
attention le nuage!
ça c'est facile
allez *rires*
qu'est ce que t'as foutu?!
toi tu n'y est pour rien, je suis médiocre
il faut l'admettre
est ce qu'on appelle quelqu’un d'autre en renfort?
oui oui oui oui oui!
OK Natsu, à toi de jouer on y va!
toc toc toc toc toc
j'ai entendu dire qu'on avait besoin d'un coup de pied ?
OUIIIIII c'est Sunsup !
t'as déjà joué ou pas ?
NAN
Mario? Les jeux de plateformes?
ouaiiis Mario kart?
Alors
c'est la même chose sauf la course, sauf les voitures, sauf les peaux de bananes
BREF
je vais dézoomer encore parce que tu es très très grande Sunsup
tu fais environ 1m de plus que moi
c'est très humiliant
mais elle a plus le bonhomme!
*incompréhensible*
ATTENNNNNNNNDDDDDD!
WOUUUUUUUHHHH
ouiiiiii
WOUUUUUUUHHHHHHHH
niveau 1 terminé! *en chantant*
attend mais pourquoi on reprend là?
*silence*
*rires*
*replay de la mort de SUNSUP*
LE CHECKPOINT
c'était un piège fallait passer au dessus, c'était un piège!
*rires + hurlements*
ah y'a eu un incident là
il s'est passé un truc incroyable ici présent!
une gerbe! beaucoup de stress!
*caméra qui tombe*
*rires*
ehh mais les filles y'as une malédiction!
si quelqu’un peut m'aider?
il trouve le moyen de faire faire aux femmes... le ménage!
*musique épique*
OOOOOOOHHHHHHHHHHH!!!! *la joie se lit sur leurs doux visages*
*rires*
mais t'as des sites bizarres!
attends mais c'est quoi ça ?
mais c'est juste un spam enfin
c'est une pub
mais attends c'est par rapport à ce que t'as déjà visité avant!
mais pas du tout!
pourquoi y est marquer: "hello Squeezie ;)"
OOOOHHHHHHHHH
VIENS TU TOMBES BIEN! VIENS LA!
ON EST AVEC LUCIOLE TRÈS BIEN!
par contre ce qu'on à vu, on en parle pas ok? parce que ça me...
tu parles de Natoo qui viens de tomber?
j'ai failli tomber *rires*
* replay de la chute de Natoo *
on a passé le niveau 1
okay
ceci est le niveau 2! à toi de jouer!
vas-y rentre dedans la
ooohhh!
oh boh
faut rentrer dans le tuyau qui est là !
mais du coup pour pouvoir rentrer dedans faut pas que tu déclenches ce cube
parce qu'il fait sortir lui
AAAAAHHHHHH
fait attention à pas déclencher le cube y'a un champignon
PUTAIN C'EST INCROYABLE
MAIS TU COMPRENDS PAS?!
STTTOOOOPPPPP
ok ok
on te sens paniquée
gauche gauche gauche!
*incompréhensible*
ATTENTION! ouais , et là tu vas dedans!
ouais et là!
normalement c'est...
ouuuuiiiiiiiiiiiiii!
donc la , y'as le petit marshmallow qui arrive
avec Natoo, on les a appeler "les gouttes de sperme"
*rires*
t'es patiente en vrai Luciole
nan j'suis toujours zen ahaa
OH ! oh?
*rires*
MAIS NAN MAIS NAN LUCIOLE LUCIOLE
NAN MAIS LUCIOLE REVIENT REVIENT
c'est stressant!
et la y'a le truc bizarre qui t'as tué chelou
AAAAAHHHHHH
va au bort et saute! ça va le déclencher !
et la tu vas dessus
AAAHH
NNOOONN
c'est vraiment SOURNOIS
ok , saute dessus pour le casser et redescend à gauche
redescend à gauche , à gauche !
voiilaaa
ohlala ! oh yes!
ah! ah l'batard!
NON!
si il vient, tu revas en arrière
vite ! vas-y ! oui ! AAAH!!
*aider moi*
*musique épique*
*saute de joie*
allez viens on va te désintoxiquer parce que t'es devenue beaucoup trop accro à ce jeu
nan parce que!
allez ! tu viens ! faut arrêter là!
nan Luciole !amener la ailleurs! elle peut plus s’arrêter!
les filles !
OUI!
oui
Luciole doit y aller :'(
OOHHHHHHH
bon courage ! ciao Luciole!
*téléportation*
eh bonsoir
EEEEEEHHHHHHH
Jenny, est ce que tu joues aux jeux vidéos ?
bien sûûûûûûr !
à gauche!
nan à droite !
me euuhh me criez pas dessus ça va me saouler!
allez! gauche GAUCHE!
gauche c'est , ce côté là
ah d'accord
en fait dès que ça commence à tomber tu vas à gauche
A DROITE!
OUI OHHHHH
mais j'ai sauté!
A GAUCHE ! A DROITE ! SAUTER!
MAIS J'AI SAUTER OOOOHHHH
*rires*
MAIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIS
attenttenttend faut qu'elle atteigne le checkpoint!
oulala
oui mais c'est foutu fallait pas les déclencher
bah oui mais bon heinn!
si c'est bon ! SII ALLEZZZZZZ!
*rires*
Jenny, il faut toujours analyser avant d'agir
j'me suis excitée
je pense qu’appeler une personne à l'aide ne suffit pas
je pence qu'appeler une seule fille en renfort ne suffira pas
il faut qu'on en appelle 2 d'un coup
OUUIIIIII
Marjo' et Karal comment ça va?
ouiii
nan mais attends c'est quoi ça?
c'est Cat Mario!
euuuhh ah mais moi j'ai amené mon petit chaudron là!
ah bah nan nan y'as pas getting over it là c'est !
#rage
le but est simple, tu dois avancer et atteindre le prochain checkpoint
le checkpoint, c'est le drapeau bleu comme là où tu es actuellement
tout à fait
eh bah super!
c'est :" tu fonces"
ATTENDEZ ME PARLEZ PAS TOUS EN MÊME TEMPS!
AAAHHHHH!
fonce! FONCE! FONCE!!
AAAHHHHHH!!
bah c'que c'que j'disais c'est que je joue AH! énormément aux jeux
mais pas du tout à ça!
j'aime bien HitMan j'aime bien...
oh mais c'est nul à chier!
t'analyses, tu vois comment faut faire pour que ça marche et tu le fait
donc en fait il faut...
R.I.P Marjorie (1990-2017)
LES AMIS, DÉJÀ! PLUS PERSONNE NE CRIE!
bah tu cries là!
oui c'est vrai
*rires*
Marjo'
oui
jpense que t'es une excellente coach
*rires*
et la pire JOUEUSE!
mais tu vas coacher Karal qui elle joue très très bien!
tu fonces à droite! nan ! ouais OUAIS!
LA ! ne prends pas le point d'interrogation!
ok c'est , faut pas!
WOUOUUUUUUUU
ok ok!
ohh jle sens pas ! oh jle sens pas!!
*musique épique*
WAAAAAAOUUUUUUH
eh on avait dit pas de cris hein
OUI BAH PAS PARDON HEIN!
alors le 2ème checkpoint
AH C'EST ÉNORME !
*murmure des "ouais"*
mais quel talent!
AH
AHH
AHHH
AHHHH
AHHHHH
AHHHHHH
AHHHHHHH
AAAHHHHHH
attend mais tu t'es fait un café en scred!
mais c'est tellement impoli!
musique épique
vous n'arrivez plus à donner l'énergie nécessaire
qu'est ce que je peux faire pour vous motiver?
DU SHOPPING! ahaha
*rires*
on s'habille toutes en rose!
ARRETERRRRRR
on fait des pancakes!!
nan j'voulais dire des cupcakes
*rires*
j'vous mets une musique , un truc qui vous motive? jvous mets quoi?
UN JOHNNY!!!!
WOUUUUUUHHH!
Johnny Hallyday  - L'envie
*cri de joie*